hello Facebook live research shows that
46% of people are overwhelmed by their
to-do list and 60% are so over committed
they cannot finish everything so every
Monday on CBS this morning we're gonna
share one thing you can do today to live
a happier healthier and more productive
life to help jump-start your week it's
all part of our new partnership with
this lovely lady who arted lovely lady
Gretchen Rubin Gretchen Rubin
award-winning podcast
it's called happier she's written a book
she's done research she knows her so are
you a happy person I am pretty happy I'd
like to think so she joins us now in our
Toyota green room with a better
alternative to shake up your to-do list
so Gretchen all the experts say to-do
lists to-do lists you're saying maybe
not you do list is not for everybody I
love it to-do list but I know that for a
lot of people that it doesn't work and
so don't think well there's something
wrong with me if I can't use it to-do
list why am I not a grown up why can't I
deal with life say well maybe there's
another way I could use a form of the
to-do list that would work better for me
it's not one size fits all yes you call
it a to Dallas number one just saying
tada you think about that people say
tada you instantly feel happy you're
saying that word right what is a to
Dallas so that's what you've already
done and especially when you're working
on like a big project where you may
think I'm working I'm working but I'm
not getting and not getting everything
crossed off my list remind yourself of
everything you've already done give
yourself in tada for all the things that
have already been accomplished and that
gives you that energy that you need to
move forward because you're like look I
have done a lot now I feel like I can do
more what makes you feel not a failure
in it yes and not discouraged you got
discs on your head and say I have
actually done some good stuff yes
because I think sometimes we set
ourselves up and we feel overwhelmed as
you've just said and when you can't do
everything you say I'm not doing nothing
right you also have nothing to show for
my day we have a lot to show for your
that you call it a could do list I like
this too so there's the to-do list and
then there's the could do list some
people don't like to be told what to do
even by themselves even by their own
list so they can just remember this is
what I choose to do this is what I could
do if I felt like it and some people
call this a Mike could list uh-huh if I
feel like it this is something I could
do and then it feels more optional it
feels more choice driven it's not like
an order that like this has to be done
it's like if you feel like it do you
feel like it you could do it
like that I think I have a could do list
all the time and don't know I have a
could do list you but
name something or give us some ideas
about things that you you think we could
do that would just make you feel happier
right away if you do such a things work
is there is there such a thing yes if
you need a quick jolt like a quick
pick-me-up you know one thing to do is
ten jumping jacks like it's kind of
goofy Gretchen who is gonna do your at
work don't believe me
think of how funny it would be if you
all of a sudden fired up ten jumping
jacks you would feel so goofy people
would be laugh that would be good you
feel good and get just or it can be
running down the stairs anything to get
your feet off the ground gives you that
kind of playful childlike sense of
energy listening to your favorite upbeat
song that's what I do like that that is
a classic absolutely because music
always makes you feel bad yes and it's
it's it's like even if you feel like you
can't do it like you could you can
connect with a friend you can have a
conversation but even if you feel like
you can't even manage that you can
listen to a good song right Gretchen
Rubin when was the last time you just
broke out into ten jumping jacks
constantly would you like to give a
demonstration here I will be wanted I
dare you oh can I get up and do it
alright okay one I usually I'm not
wearing heels if this could be make me
happier I'm trying to get that Popeyes
chicken sandwich I could do that that's
one thing that could make me happy okay
you also have a two day list like this
yes so sometimes that seems really
doable yes and that's the that's the
that's the genius of it because if
you're feeling very overwhelmed and
you're feeling like I just can't even
bring myself to think about all the
things I have to do saying well just
today what could I do today hmm not to
do in general but just for today a lot
of times that feels much more manageable
and that's something that you can work
on and then you have that feeling of
accomplishment when you've seen yourself
make progress on that list having 50
things on your list yeah in breeze you
know a good thing Gretchen Rubin we
thank you I love this partnership
between CBS this morning and you because
I know
you've sort of based your life on how to
make us all happier your research is
really been very helpful well I'm so
happy to be doing it Thank You Gretchen
uber now it's your turn ten jumping
jacks go you will feel happier